[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nicolas à ilebo nicolas acculé points
nicolas et nora vous avez satory nicolas
je crois que c'est un début le beau
gosse que j'ai vue dans ma vie entière
et non mais c'est vrai nicolas je
t'embrasse ramené à fait magnifique
vraiment aulas merci les pauvres c'est
beaucoup mais si vous avez dit avant que
votre aisance
c'est quoi un très bon moment tout le
mercier vous êtes on aimerait vous êtes
magnifique pour venir nous voir vraiment
aimé les deux ça mais j'ai envie de vous
j'ai envie qu'on nous refasse un petit
truc ah oui oui tu veux qu'il fait
encore un peu peur
mathieu a émis 1 franchement ils sont
magnifiques et ce alors l'album saturday
night fever est sorti les territoires il
faut aller boire après l'histoire ça
nous a donné envie et nicolas joue